covert 19 has battered the global
economy causing the worst recession
since the great depression of the 1930s
it will be a new economy where many
areas of the economy won't go back to
the level of output that they had before
you submitted your questions to zany
minton bedos our editor-in-chief and
edward carr our deputy editor here are
their answers
will the economic shock caused by
imposing lockdowns prove more costly
than the pandemic itself
if you are a poorer country that doesn't
have the capacity to provide the kind of
fiscal and monetary support on a scale
that advanced economies have done the
cost is is huge but secondly i think
even within the advanced world it's
interesting that countries which have
not locked down nearly as rigorously and
sweden stands out as a country that has
you know essentially not had a formal
lockdown actually has seen its economy
shrink pretty much by the same amount as
denmark right next door which had a much
much tougher lockdown and that's of
course partly because people behave in a
way which reduces economic output
they're not spending they're staying at
home but also because the overall kind
of global economic environment has been
hit so hard that that has had knock-on
effects and then the other point that's
interesting i think as we go on in time
is one it depends on how successfully
citizens
think their governments are handling
things and there i'd point um
perhaps with some concern to to the case
in the united kingdom where we are
seeing a lockdown what was implemented
somewhat later and now as a result a
government that is reluctant or is
lifting the lock down more slowly with
the result that the economic costs are
going to be really quite high and so the
the relationship between the two i think
can evolve depending on how a government
handles things and is perceived to be
handled things
how could an economic recession shift
the global balance of power
um it's come as a surprise to everybody
how the united states which in
previous
things crises like this would have
played a central role in kind of
galvanizing the world hasn't done so in
fact
it's threatened to withdraw from the
world health organization
and that
i think is a big signal um that
everybody else is going to have to come
to terms with that's not directly the
result of a recession but it's the
result of the country's response that
would have been coordinating both
medically and economically the response
to the pandemic
will this be a chance for china to
become the global financial hub
the starting point of course is that the
us is the absolutely dominant
country in global finance the dollar is
the dominant currency in global finance
whether it's the kind of plumbing of the
global financial system or the currency
that most uh central banks hold their
reserves in the question is has always
been when would that dominance be
challenged by the world's second largest
economy china but because china doesn't
have a convertible currency it's always
underplayed in global finance but i
think in the last few years and very
recently particularly we are seeing
signs that
china's
prominence will accelerate
one reason is the growing tension
between the us and china that and the us
has increasingly been using the
financial system as a weapon by imposing
sanctions the second is actually the
growth of china's own capital markets it
is developing its financial markets
but its currency is still not
convertible and so i think only when
that happens is it really going to
challenge the dollar and it is certainly
possible that the aftermath of of covert
will accelerate that this kind of thing
takes a long time to happen i mean if
you look at the last time this happened
in the 20th century when the dollar took
over from the pound it was quite a slow
process and you know long after
britain's decline was very evident the
pound was still a very important global
currency so
these transitions take a while and and
and you know it's not going to happen
anytime soon but the incentives are
clearly growing
and there is actually one reason ed i
think why this time might be a bit
faster which is
china is
um has done a huge amount to build up
the sort of financial technology
required for a digital world if you look
at the super apps within china alipay
and all of those they are much much
better and more sophisticated than than
what is in the west and so i think they
have moved ahead in actually the sort of
financialization of the digital era in a
way that could probably be exported
particularly to developing economies and
if developing economies are increasingly
going to be forced to choose which
ecosystem they're in
the china the chinese one has has some
allure there
which countries are most economically
vulnerable to the effects of covert 19
and why
the first thing to say is
the the economic effects are determined
largely by the medical effects but then
there are other things like which
particular industries are important so
tourism seems to me to be a clear
category where at least sort of one
year's tourism is going to be very hard
hit and it might go on longer if
the industry can't adapt and if there
isn't a vaccine so you should look for
industries where people
work in very close and confined
conditions some of the garment
industries where that's an important
export sector you might see that being a
problem and then others where um you
know industry and work requires people
to be very densely packed i think the
one thing i'd add to that is countries
that whose governments don't have the
capacity to borrow and to to cushion
this for their citizens
and that's particularly developing
countries heavily indebted developing
countries countries that have to rely on
dollar borrowing for them it's really
quite hard because quite often it's the
same country that has been particularly
hit because there's no tourism or
because it's a natural resource exporter
and prices have fallen and at the same
time has a heavy debt burden so if you
if you really want the kind of the ones
that that are in the toughest position i
think it's emerging economies whose
exports have been hit that are reliant
on tourism and that have a very big debt
burden
what will the impact on the jobs market
be for those graduating in 2020
that's a really good question that we've
been we've been thinking about a lot at
the economist and we did a cover a few
weeks ago which we called the the 90
economy and the argument of that cover
is that when the economy recovered we
wouldn't be going back to the old
economy it will be a new economy where
many areas of the economy won't go back
to the level of output that they had
before that's why we called it the 90
economy the other reason it's going to
be hard right now is that the
unemployment rate is high the
unemployment rate has surged and even if
it's come down in the united states a
little bit
it's still remarkably high so just
finding a job is much harder the trick
for public policy is going to be to make
sure that the scarring from that the
shadows of that don't last and what that
means is when the unemployment rate goes
up the kind of it has long-term
consequences and it takes as a result it
means that people find it harder to get
skills it's harder to sort of make a
real go of the labor market and and i
think we need to we need to work hard to
make sure that doesn't happen this time
i've seen one study in britain that says
that a third of
graduates have had their um offers
delayed or withdrawn so there's a sort
of immediate effect
the interesting thing for me is
is some of these kind of rather subtle
but perhaps important effects about what
happens when people are starting out
having just left um college
and often they go into um you know
things like um
restaurant work or bar work
things that happen in big cities
and you know that's where they make
contacts
uh where they form their own network
where they might hear about a job or
find their way into a career that they
just didn't really know they wanted
well just now those opportunities don't
really exist
and even if young people want to crowd
into cities it's not clear that many
other people will be crowding into
cities and so there might be
as annie said this 90 economy in in
which these opportunities just aren't as
readily available i mean some people are
very lucky they know they want to be a
you know computer programmer or a bridge
designer from you know the the year dot
but but most of us kind of stumble into
what we do and that stumbling is going
to be a lot harder
has the pandemic made globalization look
like a liability
i think it has in many people's eyes
made it look like a liability i don't
think it is and
you know i think one of the very wrong
conclusions to draw from this would be
for countries to put up the drawbridge
and to say that the only way to be safe
and resilient is to produce everything
at home and to to kind of end
globalization i think one of the the
lessons of this pandemic is that you you
need to diversify your supply chains we
need to rethink aspects of globalization
but i really worry that if we took this
as a signal to say that globalization
was a bad idea and that we all need to
put up the drawbridge to a more target
system that the world would be a lot
worse off
yeah i mean it's it's it's an irony
isn't it that
uh the thing about the pandemic is it
requires a global response and no more
so in finding medicines and vaccines
and then distributing and manufacturing
them and then ensuring that the best
knowledge about treatment works i mean
the best protection against a pandemic
is a globalized system
you can read all of our coverage on
kovid19 by clicking the link opposite
thanks for all your questions and thanks
for watching
you